NOW IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
#HASHTAGWARS.
OH MY GOD, YOU GUYS. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING TONIGHT,
BUT THE LONG-AWAITED SEQUEL TO
"SHARKNADO" PREMIERED ON SYFY
BUT A LIVE TWEET-STORM FOLLOWED.
WE DECIDED TO JUMP IN WITH THE
HASHTAG
#NEWSYFYORIGINALS.
SO EXAMPLES MIGHT BE, CREATURE
FROM THE DEEP SEACREST.
OR, BADGER-CANO.
OR ESCAPE FROM BIG FOOT'S
VAGINA.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND GO.
YES, BRAUNGER.
>> COBRA BONER VS. ESCAPES
MONGOOSE BOOBS.
WAIT, IS THAT -- DOES HE HAVE A
COBRA FOR A BOBER, OR IS IT A
COBRA WITH A BONER?
>> IT'S A GIANT BONER WITH A
SNAKE'S HEAD.
OH THAT'S WAY BETTER! POINTS,
GOOD. YES, HASAN.
>> BATTLE STAR GALAXITOSE
INTOLERANT.
YES POINTS. EMILY.
>> SQUIRREL-A-CANE.
YES, POINTS. BRAUNGER.
>> BICLOPS, THE BISEXUAL SICLOPS
WITH TWO EYES.
>> POINTS. EMILY.
>> GAS-SCWACH, THE HUNT FOR BIG
FART.
OK, GOOD, POINTS. HASAN.
>> ALIEN VERSUS CREDITOR.
>> YES, YES.
>> IT'S FOR ADULTS.
POINTS. BRAUNGER.
>> MASTURBATING MONKEY
HURRICANE.
>> THE SOUND OF THAT WOULD BE
TERRIFYING.
POINTS.
>> BAAAAA!
>> PAAAHHHHH. THEY'RE THROWING
IT EVERYWHERE!
EMILY.
>> TITTY TWISTER.
>> YES, POINTS.
EXCELLENT.